les quelques jours chez partis pour un
week-end plutôt sportif de l' aventure
du fun de l'émotion et aussi des grosses
galères plutôt politesse soyez les
bienvenus
[Musique]
pas mal de surprises ce week-end c'est
cool tu appelles mandela appelle moyen
terme et voilà près du mont blanc qui
est la référence du trail attentionnel
monter au courant que je comprends c'est
une race qui n'inquiète pas
[Musique]
ouais
aimer c'est la particularité c'est celui
qui fait le tour du mont blanc c'est à
dire qu'on part de parts de chamonix on
fait vraiment tour du mont blanc
c'est la seule qui fait le dos rond
et qui revient
en outre il offre 170 km dont 10000
mètres de dénivelé positif pas mal ça
soit en combien de temps dans le rhône
humain normal humain normal ça se gagne
en vain
21h pour les meilleurs la limite horaire
ses quarante six heures maximum c'est à
dire que le power
moyens morfales moyens pour une course
comme ça ça n'existe pas mais certains
cons pouvoir vont passer plus de fonds
passé deux nuits complètes dehors plus
journée puisque le départ est à 18h
faire des calculs pour ses quarante six
heures maximum show très choquée je me
fais de réchauds jeu par exemple avec
finir le cc avec ses enfants
avec six enfants clocheville mérigeau
c'est une histoire de famille et le
power qui s'entraînent toute l'année et
qui ya la famille qui fait des
concessions parce que quand on va courir
en général on va courir longtemps
week-end et on abandonne un peu tout le
monde sait ce qu'est ou pour faire
classer que tous les ans genius là
dedans tu vois quelqu'un qui passe et
tout le monde applaudit
quel que soit le parcours est là il
arrive du monde qu'il a du bon jour ils
vont revenir
parce que les arrêts
m
et voilà il ya toujours du monde pour
accueillir les 9,1 stagne mara à un
allié historique
lors de l'émission le truc sous monte
avec les familles des enfants
les dames ont jeté encore les jolies me
font pas peur vis des choses
[Musique]
non ils soient
techno
et ce soir c'est la classe allait manger
raclée vous allez même les serviettes
cros cole we have ou pas c'est quand
même un câble quand même hein alors les
tee-shirts les casquettes je veux bien
mais les servir alors qu'ils les voient
ces serviettes formation c'est que
demain on a un afterwork c'est qu'on
fait notre petite soirée ou un chalet
tous les vendredis après le départ est
donc assez la coiffure c'est là où tu
sors la serviette grosses conneries bien
sûr d'accord n'ont pas prévu pour être
sorti sur wii bravo bon appétit
j'ai passé 72 heures en immersion avec
les équipes de crosse col des passionnés
qui aiment laventure repousser les
limites
le fromage fondu les bonnes blagues et
la bière pour la bière je m'en serais
jamais douté
deuxième jour je suis arrivé hier mais
cette heure et quelques on va se jeter à
l'eau ce matin dakhla tim krause colle
d'un truc un petit peu incroyable et
surtout il ya le départ ce soir de
l'utmb ultra trail du mont blanc où je
sais pas comment les gens font pour
faire ça mais c'est ouf de voir la façon
dont les gens dont on peut se dépasser
dont on peut repousser les limites vous
faire [ __ ] dans un hôtel s'appelle le
rock hip hop hôtel c'est à côté de
chamonix c'est aux houches
le truc les vaches beaucoup c'est très
pop c'est très des 80 ou si ça trouve il
pas forcément quand vous avez dû r2d2
partout c'est un petit peu un petit peu
vintage
là on va retrouver bon petit coin kerlan
bas pour mettre toute la famille pour
mettre tout le monde et puis d'un coup
grappe est propre
c'est sympa comme autonome âge ou leur
commandant et là vous avez là où tu vas
dormir la bête voyez là c'est
sympathique c'est un joli à lui
varèse et pas trop froid j'ai
l'impression d'être tout nu à côté de
vos leur clan parents kenya alors
attendu pour ce qu'on en fait c'est pas
mal je parie grande membres non mais
c'est bien ça le petit doigt et il me
disait l'ol à combien cette fille degrés
donc la barbade pour avantage c'est que
on est au soleil et le canyon il est
court c'est un canyon on est 1h 1h30
dedans la particularité c'est qu'on
rencontre les trois spots qu'on peut
rencontrer dans tous les cas même qu'on
peut faire dans le monde c'est à dire
qu'il ya du sceau du toboggan du rappel
j'ai l'impression qu'on va voir m
normalement dans ces cas là la première
étape c'est qui nous plonge dans le
premier bain en eau du canot est
allongée
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
c'est pat lambie ensuite la condamne à
pau chinois là bas il ya plein de monde
90 de travail et à vos idées pas
pourquoi le voyais pas toute la première
ligne avec que les élites polonaises et
derrière qu'à tous les autres
connaissent actes
[Musique]
ann duffy payant est situé
non
tu as faim
m
hall 1 stand
t'es sport
avec elle
[Musique]
non
sinon
fils d'ouvrier
m
ces gars font
escape roland
[Musique]
et qui on croise au détour d'un chemin
jamais ni bounce type ppp ça va je suis
là puis c'est tellement beau cet endroit
alors le manque blank le monde blank le
mans club langue c'est un endroit génial
campus la sécurité et émouvante avec la
musique de vendée vient chanter comme ça
montre que tout cas j'étais la rentrée
sociale pourtant déjà j'étais au jour
des larmes qu'elle jeudi au moment où
j'aimerais pouvoir courir comme ça
pendant vingt ans dans les montagnes
j'aimerais être carrément un orignal
bayonne j'aimerais être un bouquetin
books c'est quoi vous demande d'être
incarnant boukari incarnions oui c'est
un vrai drame de nivelles n'a qui fait
boum taille en cours en pratique ou
rares et et on va tout les avoir pas ce
contrat dit [ __ ] absolument ça c'est
bon donc est-ce que tu installes avoir
avoir été sympa ouais pour l'instant pas
grand chose on met quand même 2
oriflammes peut marquer le coup presque
on fait notre petit le petit apéritif
pompe protocole post départ utmb way
dans notre magnifique chalet où on n'est
pas malin ouais on va juste mettre ça à
l'entrée pour montrer que c'est la
coiffure du fromage fondu quoi ah oui
déjà d'or gros tu vois je suis tellement
loin de ça je m'en rends pas être contre
les mecs en fait comment ils pensent à
leur tête on les obtient je vais me
faire un ultra trail un truc de ouf
comment tu arrives à faire l'ultra-trail
en faites pas les premiers et les
premiers trail cd oui cdd distance c'est
assez commune 15 20 km un énorme bond en
fait ça n'est pas il faut il faut voir
le trail plus comme une à notre niveau
comme une partie randonnée c'est à dire
que tu marches avec ou sans bâton
évidemment que tu cours dans la descente
parce que tu as quand même ce qu'on
disait la dernière fois des barrières
horaires à respecter s'agit pas d'aller
se balader heures dans la montagne donc
en général dès qu'un peu de dénivelé du
marché puis dès que tu peux c'est un peu
plus roulant dès que ça descend plus
courts et puis oui après tu te conduis
tu dois tu fais déjà de tant mieux après
tu challenge sur des distances un peu
plus longue parce que la notion de de
temps passé dans la montagne c'est nous
on arrive en haut on prend des photos
les premiers tu as vu comme ils sont
partis de leur fiche
c'est reparti à 15 16 km heure et ils
vont avoir fait pas ils sont sur une
moyenne de 7,8 km heure sur 170 bornes
le tient notre sport et notre discipline
voilà c'est extrême mais c'est juste que
j'ai trop grassement beau c'est que en
fait c'est ils ont fait un discours sur
les valeurs en lisant le monde par un
peu en couille
tout le monde se déteste mais avec le
sport ont réuni con mais 90 nations
différentes
et du coup les gens se retrouvent autour
de ça quelle que soit sa religion son
origine
ton pays tu as culture et sous sa
houlette actifs de de s'éclater de faire
le tour de tout 52 cet emblème de cette
montagne et ne revenir si possible avant
dimanche ces heures chaudes équipe tout
ça en fait là l'émotion
les mecs qui pleurent qui c'est fou
comme si par chance je disais ça fait
pour certains deux trois quatre ans
qu'ils attendent ce moment il ya un vrai
au delà de la sélection d'être capable
de réussir cet exploit
il faut avoir la chance d'être tiré au
sort il faut avoir la chance de me
retrouver là sur la ligne de départ
c'est pour ces âmes le grand moment où
les gens
[Musique]
et son pays
le seul regret
m
j'ai pas le malin on décolle de 2000
mètres au dessus de chamonix je pense
qu'on va être pas mal
on ne sait pas pauline s'est invitée
dans toute la salle
[Musique]
c'est la première fois qu'on voit
qu'avec
[Musique]
pour
aurélien merci décollage un breton mais
le sport extrême
c'est pas trop mon truc à la base
j'avais même pas que vous pouvez passer
au dessus de saint vol en parapente
là on est pour l'arrivée l'utmb les mecs
qui ne le font aussi des gens des gens
comment à la différence d'hier ou au
départ de la course est posée life et
une caméra mon royaume il fait super
beau c'est vachement cool que j'ai loupé
le mec qu'il arrive il ya 10 minutes
il court depuis des heures je sais pas
comment tu fais pour moi c'est les
extraterrestres et au même temps qui
courent le mec
la colère du monde 21h02 courriel
ça paraît tellement loin
c'est un exploit c'est ouf et alors le
mec du coup ce qui fait sa pub fair
value recovery star espagnole
le mec il a brûlé toute la nuit là
encore en formica n'offrent qu'un cheval
tu pourras convient bien et 3,8
moyen d'allier pendant tout plein de
détails sur les différents points de
ravitaillement ils s'arrêtent dix
minutes prendrait pas comme si l'arrêté
freitag
c'est impressionnant de voir comment le
sport peut permettre de repousser ses
limites d'aller toujours plus loin au
delà de l'imaginable
comment la volonté peut dicter au corps
le chemin parcourir des zoreys des
heures au froid la pluie l'orage
s'endormir
comment par la simple volonté du mental
qu'on peut réaliser l'impensable se
battre souvent contre soi-même pour au
final sortir grandis être le héros d'un
jour sont propres
cela qu'il a brisé le record
[Musique]
waouh
alors là on est en celui-ci on est en
suisse chez nous pas de suisse est en
fait il ya le la course
l'utmb elle part de france elle passe le
tour du mont blanc fait elle passe en
italie
voyez le truc des recours myers a certes
elle remonte en suisse là on est à la
fouly ça fait tout tout en fait
et ça revient après achat moins bon
qu'au touquet où déjà le mec qui te sors
ça en 20 heures tu dis que le niveau il
est dingue et là en fait il ya une
petite partie d'une zone qui a été
aménagé par un cross colts en plein
milieu de la nature c'est le hall
supporters je ne sais pas par où faut
passer je pense pas je peux toi mon avis
il faut qu'on monte en voiture ou
comment c'était la route aux fautifs ont
rejoint de mythos non je pense pas que
mieux la wii à la barrière qui tombe
bien c'est qu'on a pris à une autre
heureux qui monte
ok ça va ressortir mon art 8 des espèces
alors on disait donc il est grosse comme
une opération qui s'appelle le supporter
et l'idée en fait c'est que il ya les
proches des joueurs des joueurs
l'idée en fait c'est que vous avez des
proches des coureurs qui enregistre des
messages et qui les envoient cros cole
est là quand les gens arrivent et bien
le message est diffusé sur un écran et
ça alors ça en gros de booster pour le
re motiver pour le récent la cour parce
que là franchement il reste encore des
heures et des heures et des heures
déhanché et donc du coup c'est chouette
je pense qu'on va capter des trucs
chouettes voir des moments je pense que
c'est important pour les gens tu vois ce
qu'on imagine que tu cours depuis déjà
presque 24 heures des vies des terrains
c'est un peu plus et la tête fait un
boost
je pense que déjà en termes d'émotion
c'est ouf et ouais je pense que tu vas
n'ont pas dû une main il ya déjà la
maintenance et du sport et d'un point de
vue humain ça c'est sûr ça va être ta
vie de fou quoi voilà donc que moi je
découvrais c'est savoir ce que j'ai dit
ça va ok ça a dû j'ai vendu
[Musique]
bah y'a pas toi bien là il ya le 8
novembre cariou la louper donc là tu
proviens de lundi en fait j'ai toutes
les vidéos ouais elles sont classées par
niveau de sa hockey et du coup j'ai mon
collègue m'a lancé de 50 chez accor
hilton n'a pas tout de suite pour
l'instant quirion là pendant ce temps
mais combien il y en a mille dix pardo
et après tu diffuses le tuc ou la
batterie autonome de
on a à peu près 8 heures d'autonomie
avec sa wii du coup on allume la télé le
pc dessus en disant hdmi et quand t'as
pas de mec quaritch passe par une petite
partie de fifa ou un truc comme ça bah
ouais mais faut qu'on garde un peu de
batterie parce que si on veut c'est beau
la production je suis né qu'est ce que
tu as fait black magic pockets [ __ ]
c'est bon ça arrive ça 3 sets 0
casquette blanche soit 0 casquette
blanche ok on est revenu exactement ça
tu le prends tes objectifs
ouais comme ça c'est de la belle émotion
ses larmes
on est alors un petit coup là exactement
soit homogène
[Rires]
[Musique]
non
qu'ils veulent chez nous
[Musique]
oui
ayew à
taxi alors pour la foudre quand on est
sur un truc un peu de métal tu vois on
va tous crever en a trop finalement
c'est sans engagement fataliste non mais
oui non voilà donc on assiste aussi au
chômage et tout va bien
[Musique]
loin du but au polygone va composer de
dire qu'ils allaient faire score je n'ai
pas lu les livres des vêtements
sous la tente et parcourir
là il fait un temps dégueulasse même là
là c'est un peu dégueulasse
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
c est aussi un équidé sonore bon le truc
un peu con orages qui s'approche va
éviter de mourir donc mis en sécurité
vos clientes le dispositif c'est contre
super chouette mais bon là une petite
tente comme ça et voilà
ah ça c'est là au torse a fait 25 heures
de cours
vingt-cinq heures qui courent l'art est
prêt ce sens qu il
ce sont 10 km donc les maîtres
potentiellement il arrive demain et non
dans ce cas ça me prend
16h02 ma poire
et nous on n'est pas français ouais
ouais est en fait le mec il s'illustra
ses coûts s'il faut souvent les mêmes
d'ailleurs qui dit non mais non stop les
images saintes est le retaper
mais déjà je comprends pas les mecs qui
courent on se dit que le mec il a fait
25 heures
moi j'ai cours 20 minutes je suis mort
qu'est ce qu'un financement d'ahmed
collector c'est donc un apu pont
on sait pas vraiment en fait ce qui se
passait il ya qu une seule route
ok ça c'est juste les terres on
en fait-on
pour du propre
il en est beaucoup plus
et par l'italie à 2h et mieux dans
youtube par
[Musique]
plus on y apprend il coulait terre lune
coup l'éditeur il ya plus de points ya
plus de 10 ces voix là c'est les aléas
de la météo mais à l'extrême
il ya peu de ciel bleu et là je pense
que c'était il ya plus de pauillac
oppose ya plus de pourrir un peu de
temps c'est ça la hauteur ans et jamais
le vol autor l'un et merci de m'avoir
merci de m'avoir invité
il ya près de pau il ya plus de pau par
un tu peux faire ta vidéo ce soir comme
ça demain c'est oublier ta mon ordi il
ya plus de pourrir plus de poids au sein
de sap all in que ce qui se passe à
bandol l'état de la route et c'est parce
que je crois qu'il ya un truc en fait
qu'ils pourront froid que l'utmb ne veut
pas cette année là la non non non non
[ __ ] c'est chaud c'est voulait tous
les côtés j'ai l'impression qu'on allait
coincer ont appelé les secours il va
remonter ou attend le choix oui oui où
la fiesta le chandail rouge par couche
par couche pas vas-y vas-y tu es là tu à
l'argenté large encore un peu impolie il
m'a dit encore a pas cependant s'annonce
avance de kourou droite et reviens me
chercher
ok ça bouge pas c'est bon je peux monter
le long de la rivière 44.44 cantine clio
thank you
bon ben on va passer la nuit
de l'autre côté je voyais pas l'intérêt
de rentrer en france ce soir tu vois les
maquis en chine nous aussi c'est la
voiture éboulements teint des deux côtés
tinseau line en fait la voiture tu sais
il faut fermer les met dans les voitures
seront cotées mais [ __ ] c'est à vous
taire regarde moi ma bouteille ou à
l'étranger
tu sais quoi
voiture piscine tu sais quoi moyer
jusqu'au bout pas comme côtoient pas
semblé j'espère ça c'est rassurant quand
la voiture demain
un après midi sur sec j'espère
bon la puce est calme et le rush et
qu'elle mais l'opération supporters se
peut continuer avec un changement de
spots
là on est pas mal la nuit va tomber le
problème qu'il ya un éboulement de
terrain d'un côté un éboulement terrain
notre côté donc pour l'instant les
comptes sont bloqués on peut passer même
pas si on va rentrer ce soir pour
pouvoir dormir à l'hôtel
non peu importe quelle aventure en tout
cas c'est ça qui est vraiment cool voilà
bienvenue dans mon dos là où dorment six
heures
[Musique]
kawasaki
qu'un seul club
m
non
costes oui est ce que c'est ça les élus
cause le transfert donc des news sur la
route
en fait d'après cinq mineurs qui est
déjà des matchs la nouvelle bonne voilà
un mois qu'ils mettent les bouchées
doubles mais bon je pense que casino
boîte de nuit on prend tous là
[Musique]
gwe
ils ne
ce palais
[Musique]
rien
holmes
youtube
c'est ça la réalité sa cause
ravitaillement il ferme dans un quart
d'heure
donc si t'es pas parti dans un quart
d'heure en fait ils gardent tactique
c'est la réalité la guardia
les yeux et corps et tout ce qui va se
passer un bon des gens qui sont plus
lents non
sans l'adhésion
ouais non
notez dans vos sacs plastiques dessus
car
les enfants à besoins en fait les voiles
oui si l'on regard hagard concrètement
un gars et l'a10 des troupes
actuellement
et tu dis pas que tu vas partir courir
pour aller voir
15 heures
imac à ces arguments
arrêt
prix intérieurs
commentaire
trop tard
il ne peut pas partir parce que le gros
des cassettes séjour dont les plus haut
placés raisons qui à vendre ici sont du
coup également invoquées sont la
tigresse de chute rien pour
d'information le service de la mobilité
du canton du valais a mis tout en oeuvre
pour rénover la route du val ferret en
principe par deux heures 20h30 au [ __ ]
var où doit être ouverte ya pas de
suprise
concernant le fond beau et qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire quand on doit attendre
qu'est ce que vous auriez fait à notre
place merci monsieur merci ça c'est
important mais à peine chauffés
merci au delà pour les jours de la
chopine reste de la bande le shopping
monsieur la chopine 3 3 ça flingue les
maquis kim père la rigueur ce qu'il a vu
bailly arrive plus iris et moi
tranquille il est en pleine récupération
la drague mais aggravées harry le
prévoit le règlement
j'adore économiste pour le soutien qu'on
va faire genre à peu près quatre heures
tu pas notre langue green a cédé 0,36 il
est 0 h 36 le tas qui font le pont est
ouvert on va pouvoir rentrer voir on
peut rentrer à chamonix
est-ce qu'on va rentrer en vie et
chamonix bout on va voir on laisse
passer les concurrents
si jamais le pont s'écroulent les
concurrents d'abord et nous après merci
pour moi merci banier on va reprendre le
pont donc la cei avait la coulée de boue
bien pour ya un pont cabinet un [ __ ]
de bordel
donc là il la coulée de boue love away
et l'est où le pont on va tomber mourir
tu as vu le fond et on a roulé c'est
quoi la volée sur quoi bon donner envie
à tout va bien la suite et vous nous
tranquille mais je ramène ou aux mails
mars
on est des vrais est ce que vous savez
que nous on se retrouve dans un
éboulement coulées de boue bloqués en
mer c'est que tu es survécu ici vous
êtes vous êtes des horreurs tu vois ce
qu'ils vont arriver bien commun qui vont
arriver lance ou pas voilà gardien
groupe de sang
donc là ça fait combien coûte un
profiteur quand les dimanches matins il
est 9h et des boîtes et les mecs qui
courent depuis vendredi soir 18 heures
sauf à ses tenues dans le froid
pire elle
oui debout avec des dénivelés ou frankie
paul anka
[Musique]
m
dubaï
[Musique]
tb
placez y créer
nous et de nos gammes ce tueur est fait
faits saillants
[Musique]
lee
à
72 heures en immersion totale avec les
équipes de crosse col j'ai vécu des
moments inoubliables qu'il resterait
gravé à jamais c'est surtout une
aventure humaine
dépassement de soi vaincre ses peurs ses
préjugés travailler en équipe pour
donner le meilleur
ne jamais renoncer une jeune reculer et
à l'arrivée la fierté
[Musique]
merci cros coll